dure année pour le fabricant du rwanda
il a été condamné aux états unis à
l'issue de deux nouveaux procès qui
associe encore une fois son pesticides
au cancer et qui conclut que le
fabricant savez la compagnie en appel
des jugements et les milliards accordés
en dommages ont été ramenés par les
tribunaux à 200 millions de coûteux
revers judiciaire dû en grande partie
aux révélations embarrassantes de cet
homme travaille chez manson qui depuis
environ trente trois ans hayden
toxicologue chez monsanto pendant 33 ans
directeur de la sécurité des produits
ces courriels divulguées lors des procès
révèle au monde entier comment le
fabricant est allé jusqu'à s'immiscer
dans la rédaction d'articles
scientifiques prétendument est dépendant
même ici au canada
on vous a déjà parlé d'une publication
fondamentale qui a eu une grande
influence sur les autorités
réglementaires partout dans le monde
la publication était cité des centaines
de fois elle résume des recherches
publiées et d'autres faites par le
fabricant sur la dangerosité du roundup
elle a été produit par une firme de
consultants ontarienne chemtox elle
conclut que le rand up ne pose aucun
risque pour la santé humaine
cette publication est signée par trois
chercheurs williams kroes et monroe ian
monroe et l'ancien fonctionnaire de
santé canada devenu président de centex
on vous avait aussi expliqué comment bel
hayden admettait candidement dans ses
courriels que les experts n'auraient
fait que réviser et apposé leur
signature
rappelez vous c'est ce que nous avions
fait avec williams cause et monroe en
c'est ainsi que vous avez traité
williams rose et monroe vous l'avez
écrit il non révisés et signer ma
mémoire à jean trahir ce n'est pas ce
qui s'est produit avec royaume strauss
est mort j'ai dû me tromper se défend
bel hayden avant d'admettre avoir
apporté des changements ou manuscrits
j'ai apporté ma contribution et le
moment où j'ai reçu manuscrit j'ai
fourni quelques modifications et
réécritures se tait mineurs parmi ces
changements il a fait retirer du contenu
de la publication a scrupuleusement
suivi son évolution et s'est assuré d'en
faire la révision finale
nous avons demandé ce qu'il en pense à
l'avocat des victimes aux états unis
brentwood ne il nous a accordé une
nouvelle entrevue à partir de studio de
los angeles scientifique
c'est invisible c'est pour ça qu'on
appelle ça de ghostwriting les gens ne
voient pas l'implication de la compagnie
ça peut être pernicieux prenait
l'apparence d'indépendance
parce qu'une étude signée par des
employés du fabricant serait moins
crédibles d'autres courriels divulguée
récemment semblent confirmer la lourde
d'implications de monsanto dans la
publication au canadien ian monroe censé
être un des auteurs il écrit enfin voici
le texte les tableaux et les références
je me suis fait plusieurs nouveaux
cheveux gris en écrivant ce truc donc
écrire cet article vous a donné des
cheveux gris oui avec le recul je
faisais probablement allusion à la
longueur du processus
nous allons présenter les témoignages
docteur hayden au procès quand il dit je
n'ai pas fait ça et qu'on lui montre le
document qui disent le contraire procès
plusieurs jurés sont venus me dire sur
with no comment peut-il mentir ainsi su
serment ce n'est que la neuvième version
du manuscrit que le docteur hayden se
propose aux canadiens est une neuro tout
le monde chez monsanto est d'accord pour
ajouter ton nom aux auteurs s'il te
plaît fais le vous écrivez tout le monde
chez monsanto est d'accord pour ajouter
ton nom hauteur s'il te plaît fais le
est ce bien lui
vous avez bien lu je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'écris cela il était toujours
prévu que in serait un des auteurs de
ces oublis et les hésitations du témoin
n'ont pas échappé aux jurys croit
brentwood n'est pas que de la
manipulation de la science c'est
trompeur voilà pourquoi le jury accorde
des dommages punitifs aussi élevé
quinze ans plus tard monsanto se tourne
une nouvelle fois vers la firme
canadienne chemtox devenu intertek le
glyphosate vient d'être classé
cancérigène probable par le centre
international de recherche sur le cancer
le glyphosate classé comme cancérogène
probable chez l'homme par le centre
international de recherche sur le cancer
il serait également nocif pour
l'environnement
monsanto crainte un effet dévastateur
sur son produit vedette et veut frapper
fort pour discréditer l' agence de l'onu
et ses conclusions elle recrute 15
chercheurs via intertek une forte
influence de monsanto sur ces experts et
par la compagnie a décidé qu'ils
feraient quoi one one ring
sans grande surprise les quinze
affirment unanimement que le glyphosate
n'est pas dangereux mais douze des
quinze oublie de divulguer qu'ils ont
déjà été consultant payé par monsanto
dans le passé leurs travaux auront
encore une fois une grande influence
dans le monde et encore une fois des
riders on surveille l'évolution propose
des changements à etterbeek
quand on le questionne sur ces
changements sa réponse est étonnante
je ne sais pas ce qu'il a fait de mes
commentaires je n'ai jamais pris la
peine de vérifier qu'il ne s'est pas
soucié de savoir ce qui est advenu de
ces changements
sa contribution est un autre détail que
les auteurs ont tout oublié de
mentionner dans leurs déclarations de
conflits d'intérêts sadi aucun employé
ou avocats de monsanto n'a révisé les
travaux des experts avant leur
soumission pour publication vous voyez
cela monsieur je vois que c'est écrit là
c'est totalement faux n'est ce pas
honnêtement je ne sais pas ce qu'il
voulait dire
parmi les auteurs se trouve qu'ils se le
mot il est au psychologue professeur
émérite de l'université de guelph en
ontario
il s'est beaucoup penché sur le
glyphosate au cours de sa carrière
le docteur sur le monde travaille
étroitement avec monsanto depuis au
moins vingt trente ans layton leurs
experts exposure gaye
et cette fructueuse collaboration a fait
deux kits seulement un allié précieux
semble-t-il c'est un des experts de
notre côté écrivent d'entre eux des
employés de monsanto
c'est même un ambassadeur qui défend nos
produits et notre science le docteur
solomons nous a répondu naître
ambassadeurs que de la bonne science sur
la santé humaine et environnementale et
que les études commandées par
l'industrie fait au centre de
toxicologie qu'il dirige respecte les
meilleures pratiques de laboratoire
ce n'est pas la première controverse
pour le professeur aujourd'hui retraité
il a souvent défendu l' usage des
pesticides
ce qui lui a valu sa part de critiques
dans cette entrevue au réseau global il
ya quelques années on lui demandait s'il
peut être objectif quand ces travaux
sont payés par un fabriquant de
pesticides
le fabricant nous a répondu que les
publications de cannes tox et des terres
tech reflètent l'opinion de leur auteur
et qu'ils avaient été révisée par des
pairs que l'application mineurs de
monsanto n'a pas influencé leur
conclusion est qu'en dépit des
inquiétudes soulevées devant des
tribunaux des grandes autorités
réglementaires dans le monde continuent
d'approuver le glyphosate
[Musique]